[Musique]
je
bonjour à tous je m'appelle à marivaux
depuis le 12 octobre dernier nous avons
commencé une émission en direct sur
notre site web mais aussi en facebook
live une émission qui s'intéresse aux
enjeux autochtones et nous en avons
couvert beaucoup énormément d'enjeux
autochtone
quand j automne évidemment on s'est
intéressé aux premières nations aux
inuit mais également aux métis parmi les
sujets qu'on a abordé on a traité de
santé on a traité d'emploi de musique
des femmes autochtones d'architecturé
également d'appropriation culturel de
littérature on s'est intéressé aux
changements climatiques à la gouvernance
et j'en passe nos invités d'ailleurs je
le souligne ils ont été à au moins 98 %
des autochtones des autochtones qui
vivait soit dans leur communauté ou
encore ici en ville et ses invités l'a
donc se sont donnés généreusement pour
parler de leur réalité
alors je vous dis tout ça en fait parce
que nous allons faire une pause pour
l'été nous allons terminer avec cette
émission là et nous reprendrons le 23
août prochain
mais ce que je vous propose aujourd'hui
c'est un best-of donc les meilleurs
moments les invités qui nous ont captivé
qui nous ont intéressés des invités qui
ont remué des émotions également vous
allez les découvrir au fur et à mesure
donc plusieurs la première invitée ce
seront des extraits d'entrevues
évidemment donc la première c'est michel
houde et michèle audette c'est une innu
qui est né à wabush au labrador c'est
une militante une leader autochtone
commissaire aline fadal enquête
nationale sur les femmes et les filles
autochtones assassinées et disparues
et elle nous avait livré un pan de sa
vie
alors cette entrevue là elle avait eu
lieu le 9 novembre ça c'était à quelques
jours de la conférence sur la prévention
du suicide
une conférence qui s'appelait dialogue
pour la vie 2018 est à nous avait
raconté ce qu'ils avaient mené un jour à
vouloir se suicider et pourquoi ils
préfèrent maintenant jongler avec la vie
plusieurs événements je vous dirais du
moment de ma naissance jusqu'à jusqu'en
2013 où on subit on nous impose
on nous force on nous surprend avec soin
comment était mon mode de vie à l'époque
que ce soit la communauté ou une
agression sexuelle une violence latéral
le divorce de mes parents la
consommation toxicomanie donc c'est
plusieurs plusieurs plusieurs événements
qui fait que ça devient une couche une
peau comme un oignon de maisons plus
lourd à porter et 2013 va avoir été
extrêmement difficile où un comme
superwomen à cette époque là c'est ce
que je pensais que je t'aime tellement
j'étais dans l'esprit sont ouverts
planète avec le mouvement des femmes de
ville harcèlement au travail de vivre
une séparation sa ramener tous ces
monstres là où ces couches et un moment
donné
la dernière action pour moi et souffler
puis capable de respirer plus capable de
vivre le suicide était
la porte de 0,10 exactement mais merci
la vie je suis contente aujourd'hui
d'être vivant et je retournerais plus
lol alors je le disais on en parle parce
que cette semaine c'est la conférence
dialogue pour la vie 2018 et justement
le thème c'est favoriser une vie
d'espoir avec et pour nos enfants et nos
jeunes parce que c'est vrai que souvent
c'est à l'adolescence il ya tellement de
changements dans nos vies les
traumatismes qu'on peut avoir vécu plus
jeunes remontent à la surface et on est
conscient à ce moment là en fait est ce
qu'on l'ait conscient du geste qu'on
voudrait poser mais on le réfléchit on
le rejette moite que c'était comme ça
j'allais pas chercher de l'aide mais je
réfléchissais puis au moment où c'était
le temps de passer à l'action où je me
donnais le temps là je refusais je me
pensais mais coup sur coup et
action par dessus une autre jetez plus
capable alors j'ai essayé toutes sortes
de manières ce matin-là le fusil une
surconsommation médicale médicaments
plus d'autres choses et je tombe endormi
avec le fusil des mets donc ça c'était
c'était un acte du créateur ou d'une
grand mère qui me surveillent le mais il
ya un moment donné on sait même plus moi
qui avais le contrôle sur moi le fait
que et à partir de ce moment là j'ai
j'ai accepté d'avoir cette dépression la
cette grande peine là d'avoir la
faiblesse ou le leu de nier que j'ai
besoin d'un oui et je me suis accrochée
au mollet physiquement du médecin à
l'hôpital d'amiens
si j'en ressors jour mourir je me
connais la puis j'aime trop la vie
d'habitude donc aider moi oui est ce que
c'est une réalité particulière chez les
autochtones
je dirais je suis pas surprise
d'entendre
mes collègues et amis des témoignages
les gens que j'ai côtoyés dans le passé
qu'on a eu plusieurs idées noires aux
tentatives de tristement voir aussi les
statistiques très élevé chez les
autochtones depuis trop longtemps
c'est que où il ya une violence physique
émotionnel et spirituel et mentales qui
existe dans les communautés oui il ya
d'autres couches ou d'autres dont un
niveau qui n'existe pas chez mes soeurs
québécois ce qui est une loi sur les
indiens une dépossession du territoire
la perte d'identité comme charles parle
elle a la fierté au niveau de l'identité
beaucoup de choses qui nous ont été
enlevés quand je parlais d'imposer dans
l'introduction qui font très très mal et
à cette époque l'offre réalisais pas que
ça faisait partie de mes grandes france
parlant d'identité vous avez en plus une
double identité
est ce que c'est un enjeu aussi dans
cette recherche de savoir qui on est ce
qu'on vaut oui oui très jeune quand on
accumule cette forme de viol violences
la gg huit ans
et à chaque fois que je retourne à
maliotenam donc 8,1 après se disant
passe à 12 ans ou des adultes vont me
cracher dessus me lancer des objets mais
crier après que je te voleuse de job
mais je tiens enfin là je trouve une
petite fille et par la suite c'est une
violence qui est physique en disant tu
étais pas dit si tu es pauvre et
indienne
donc les blessures elle vient de tous
bords sans l'avoir demandé parce que ma
mère est tombée amoureuse du plus beau
québécois qui mon papa c'est plus tard
que à reprenant contrôle sur ma vie dans
la feuille vingtaine ou là je me dis mon
dieu c'est un cadeau des ti nous et
québécoise donc j'aime processus de
guérison l'a fait en sorte que mais dans
la grande dépression 2013 les vues m'ont
sont revenus pareil pourquoi les violons
sont revenus à ce moment là parce que
quand convient de l'harcèlement dans un
milieu où dans une famille où on vit une
situation de violence et plusieurs
formes de violence
moi c'est pas que je pensais que j'étais
guérie
j'étais guérie d'un certain passé et que
je ne faisais au dans la vérité je
faisais juste le temps c'est le maître
de collonges présenter la superwoman
carrément c est en 2013 c'est là où j'ai
ouvert toutes ces portes là parce que la
médecin la docteure look est doué on va
prendre finalement on a ouvert une à une
toutes ces portes là pour amener le
pardon qui a mené l'amour certains je
suis obligé de pardonner mais de dire
bientôt je te laisse la piqûre n'ai pu
me déranger mais cela c'était
fondamental fallait le faire
le 23 novembre moi j'étais absente mais
mon collègue guy bois m'a remplacé et il
a eu la chance de discuter avec la
présidente de femmes autochtones du
québec viviane michel viviane s'est uni
nous qui est originaire de malioténam
elle est à montréal depuis longtemps
puisqu'elle est attaché donc à femmes
autochtones du québec et
mon collègue qui lui avait posé la
question suivante est ce qu'on peut
parler de féminisme autochtone voici ce
qu avait à lui dire viviane michel on a
de la difficulté avec le mot féminin et
on a déjà fait un exercice nos danses
travailler avec la maison communautaire
snac une maison victimes
pour les femmes victimes de violences et
on a fait d'exercer sur comment on
perçoit le mot féminisme on s'est senti
comme en danger et on s'est sentis on a
ressorti toutes nos craintes et on n'a
pas le don de catégoriser les choses que
l'on fait dans l'exemple la population
québécoise a le don de catégoriser les
féministes paternaliste cetera donc nous
on fait des choses on concrétise des
choses en lutte sur certains enjeux mais
c'est pour les nôtres oui et pour vous
justement vous avez employé le mot quels
sont les prix spots enjeux qui guette
les femmes autochtones gouro c'est tout
l'enjeu de là tout l'enjeu de la
sécurité je vous écoute est à la
commission vient vous disiez ghislain
picard le chef de l'assemblée des
premières nations du québec et du
labrador a renchéri aussi vous parliez
de droit à la sécurité
évidemment les enjeux les gros en ce qui
touche nos femmes aujourd'hui sont
vraiment la discrimination systémique
le raciste systémique incluant le racé
systémique évidemment et l'impunité qui
est existant plan des groupes dangereux
de violence où on a pu voir avec le code
des femmes autochtones disparues et
assassinées
avec aussi les femmes qui ont dénoncé la
brutalité policière
ou est ce que ne sont pas protégés et
c'est ce qu'on dénonce aujourd'hui la
sécurité qui est pas donnée pour les
femmes autochtones dont on peut faire
ressortir leur assist system etc et la
discrimination existantes bon justement
vous êtes à femme autochtone vous êtes
là depuis 2012 c'est bien ça alors oui
donc c'est votre dernier mandat quels
sont vos objectifs quel est votre
programme
mon programme a été on part avec les
mandats que les femmes nous donne
beaucoup sur la gouvernance défend
maintenant la place des femmes dans la
vie dans ces eaux dans le panier
du monde élus du monde politique et en
même temps on a aussi les deux
commissions qui vont terminer donc ça va
prendre un gros coup de pouce pour faire
réaliser les recommandations qui vont
être déposées
nous mêmes nous allons déposer des
mémoires à chacune des commissions avec
des recommandations qui va avec la
réalité des femmes et à la demande des
femmes évidemment et à la demande des
familles pour l'autre commission donc il
ya saison je la mets aussi comment
maintenant on va travailler ensemble ça
c'est vraiment un gros défi 500
exerçaient encore les formes coloniale
il ya beaucoup de gens qui nous
approchent
sauf qu'ils aient encore des formes
coloniale qui sont exercées on décide
pour nous on croit que c'est bien ce
qu'ils écrivent par rapport à un autre
donc l'inclusion la consultation et la
concertation est vraiment importante
pour faire monter le ton du québec
oui vous avez employé le mot forme
coloniale est-ce que vous avez des
exemples
donc nous donner les formes cologna
s'est on a déjà fait affaire avec un
ministère nos dons patrimoine canada
patrimoine canada est une entité qui
exercent vraiment les formes coloniale
on doit toujours répondre à leur façon à
leurs besoins et on doit toujours
s'adapter
ça a été vraiment très déchirant de
travailler avec cette entité qui
exercent et forme coloniale et
paternaliste évidemment parce que
c'était tellement visible j'avais
tellement le goût de dire mais c'est
quoi ces formes coloniale et à
l'intérieur quand tu dépends d'un
financement qui te fait fonctionner je
te limite parfois a vraiment un talent
et les choses qui doit être dit oui
alors là vous touchez de la question de
la dépendance économique des
organisations autochtones et voilà et on
sait que toutes les organisations
autochtones sont en mode survivance
économique même que les communautés à
l'intérieur des communautés sont aussi
en mode survivance économiques dans leur
fonctionnement
oui et quand vous rencontrez les
fonctionnaires que ce soit les
fonctionnaires québec où les
fonctionnaires à ottawa et quand vous
leur dit mais arrêtez de nous prendre
pour des enfants arrêter cette forme de
colonialisme et là on vous répond quoi
écoutez je pense que beaucoup
d'éducation à faire avec les
gouvernements
c'est de faire reconnaître qui nous
sommes et de faire reconnaître qu'à une
loi paternaliste qui a été émis en 1760
détour on est en 2018
et elle est encore long on prend de la
loi sur les indiens qui discrimine
beaucoup les femmes
dans ce système et qui regardez moi ces
56 ans aujourd'hui
mais d'après la loi sur les indiens
équivaut à 17 ans ce n'est pas ce droit
de choisir ce n'est pas ce pouvoir de
d'avoir une vision pour mon peuple
le 1er février donc là nous sommes en
2019 nous avons reçu une artiste une
attikameks en fait c'est une autodidacte
elle est originaire de la communauté de
manouane cet automne en fait l'automne
dernier cet automne ou et 2018 elle a
réalisé une immense murale une murale de
la cinéaste abénaquise alanis obomsawin
m
si vous ne l'avez pas vu c'est à
montréal sur la façade d'un édifice du
centre-ville
évidemment elle n'a pas fait que ça son
portfolio et remplis d'oeuvres qui sont
plus fortes plus importantes les unes
que les autres et donc elle est venu
nous visiter et là je lui ai demandé si
c'était important pour elle d'être une
femme bien sûr mais une femme artiste
autochtone on l'écouté oui c'est
important de d'être fiers et d'être une
femme aussi parce que il se passe
quelque chose dans ce moment dans le
monde les femmes sont sont en train de
serrer les coudes et c'est il ya
beaucoup plus de femmes aussi qui
travaillent dans l'industrie du cinéma
ou dans le monde de l'art d'un désert
puis c'est ce merveilleux
et vous alors justement tu fais partie
de ces modèles autochtones qui sont des
modèles pas seulement pour les
autochtones mais pour la société en
général
et on pourrait regarder le site espace
autochtone rêver aux et construire sur
ces jeunes je me dire si tu en connais
certains de ces jeunes qu'on a présenté
une quinzaine de portraits environs de
jeunes autochtones de partout à travers
le pays qu'on avait envie de faire
découvrir
il va me boivin évidemment c'est le
premier qui envahit vienne manawan dont
il connaît bien lui at on va les
regarder
il y en a plusieurs ça vient de l'ouest
du pays
évidemment ça vient aussi du grand nord
ces jeunes là viennent de l'est du pays
du centre thomass géruzet qu en face et
ce jeune homme qui travaille à
l'université mcgill celui qui aimerait
bien faire changer le nom des équipes
sportives là les redmen
hier cette femme qui est incroyable
donne un mets qui marlou juke qui veut
devenir une chirurgienne cardiaque
as tu déjà entendu parler d'elle non toi
change jamais non plus ses côtés des
nouveaux visages que je découvre la
personnalité des je me dis on voit
beaucoup les artistes sont très présents
les voit beaucoup mais cela qu'ils sont
pas dans le milieu des arts qui n'ont
pas la lan mais cette tribune médiatique
le on y voit pas les on les entend pas
un chirurgien cardiaque pour moi ces
sessions des plus grands
accomplissements pour les premières
nations
négocié à triste autochtones à
lichtenberg c'est incroyable non c'est a
bien raison ce sont des gens dont on
entend rarement parler évidemment une
tribune comme ça ça permet de la deûle
et mettre de l'avant de montrer leur
travail pis c'est ça il ya ivan boivin
flammes en pâmoison dylan boivin flamand
ben c'est un musicien talentueux qui
joue de la guitare puis il part souvent
tourné
depuis très longtemps un manhwa non non
non et les radios à melo idée sur la
route soins pour pour sa musique
c'est un virtuose qu'il est et il a pris
sable lui même pas leur est il possible
toi même tu es une artiste autodidacte
on a appris par moi-même
ouais j'apprends tout je suis jamais
allé à l'université j'ai juste fait une
session de cégeps avait des mauvaises
notes
mais j'apprends tout moi même puis et
tout va bien de ton art oui ces
travailleuses autonomes
je vis de mon arrêt je fais de l'argent
de poche comme ça puis sont passés de
l'argent pour vivre
est ce que tu es connu en dehors du
québec est ce qu on te connaît de plus
en plus ailleurs au canada ailleurs à
l'étranger
un jeu j'ai des amis et je je veux pas
je pense que oui mais les genres plus le
sens commun les gens connaissent du sme
en amont mon travail que moi genre et là
je remarque qu'on a reçu beaucoup dit
nous dans ces extraits là mais j'avoue
tout au long de des différentes
émissions que nous vous avons proposé
une autre île où cette fois ci en fait
un nid nous il ne provient de la
communauté de pessamit tu es comme
michèle audette lui aussi l'a côtoyé le
suicide à plusieurs reprises mais comme
michèle audette
il a choisi la vie et en plus il a
choisi aussi de faire du bien aux autres
alors il est chirurgien et il a plein de
projets qu'il réalise dans les
communautés très souvent avec les jeunes
je pense que vous l'avez reconnu c'est
le docteur stanley vollant
il est venu nous voir c'était le 8
février
il est venu avec valérie veine qui est
une conseillère en crise sociale c'était
à l'occasion de la 29e semaine nationale
de prévention du suicide
et pendant qu'ils étaient là pendant son
intervention il a expliqué lui lui dans
son cas ce qui l'avait conduit au
suicide plusieurs fois en 2007 lors
d'une séparation j'ai fait une
dépression
et le cadre de ma dépression quelques
semaines après j'ai plus fusil et gelé
mis dans la bouche et j'étais sur le
point de tirer sur la gâchette et
seulement dans les écrits je devais
faire pour mes équipes de dieu j'avais
oublié paragraphe puis à ce moment là
j'avais un blackberry et un toujours un
bouton il y avait un bouton send essaye
de l'est comme ça et vega mini miss et
vimont mon texte et j'ai fait scène par
erreur et chose est mon ami qui est un
agent dit même lörrach immédiatement
parce que ça commençait par la phrase
suivante louis quand on recevra le email
je suis mort rappelle la police presse
mondadori
je suis leur expliquer le pourquoi et le
comment c'est pas arrivé je suis très
content aujourd'hui et je peux témoigner
que ma ville le les pressions des fois
on n'est pas sur le marché dans la
noirceur de marché à la plus grande des
noirs ça la plus froide la plus longue
mais le salé finit toujours par tourner
et il s'est levé pour moi ç'a pris du
temps
j'ai des gens qui m'a accompagné qui
m'ont tenu la main à travers cette
longue nuit qui m'a paru interminable et
aujourd'hui
dix ans après chant corps vivant et je
fais du bien au monde et je sauve des
personnes et aujourd'hui même ga j'ai
appris qu'un un ami très proche dans une
grande détresse et je viens de
je dois lui parler après midi donc juive
personnellement un événement très très
proche encore du sud et le suicide je l'
ai vécu à plusieurs reprises à travers
mes marche des gens qui m'ont parlé de
leur expérience
il nous met chez nous cette longue
marche de kw à 6000 km que vous avez
fait là au cours des dernières années
oui ça vous a permis d'aller à la
rencontre de jeunes qui avaient
peut-être justement ce genre d'idées
noires énormément je pense que selon
celle-ci qu'on parle de 40% des
autochtones qui auraient des idées
noires des suicidaires
ce qui est nettement supérieur à la
moyenne canadienne mais de façon
personnelle de façon biaisée peut-être
les gens qui viennent me voir peut-être
des gens qui avaient des pragmatiques je
voudrais une grande grande majorité des
gens qui ont exprimé à voir passer à
travers des périodes très très noir et
penser au souci donc pour moi -
échantillonnage personnel c'est de 60 à
80 % des gens et ça remonte je pense que
c'est le sait c'est peut-être la pointe
de l'iceberg d'un phénomène qui est plus
important c'est le traumatisme
trans-générationnel que nos vécus depuis
la colonisation les pensionnats la
violence dans nos canaux tekki rouvrir
le sort et le docteur stanley vollant
nous a expliqué aussi pourquoi il faut
aller chercher les forces et surtout
promouvoir la vie dans les communautés
si on ne gère que les crises pendant
deux trois semaines on envoie des forces
spéciales des climats tactique pour
aller régler la crise la pression on
oublie des communautés pendant des mois
et des mois et il faut pas justement il
faut développer des forces comme madame
veine disait des forces pour moisson de
la santé globale promotion de l'aide de
la vie parce que la vie c'est le plus
beau cadeau c'est souvent avec un
constat le matin c'est peut-être le
gâteau le plus difficile parce que bon
faut se lever il fallait travailler il
faut affronter le froid il faut
affronter les des épreuves mais nos
ancêtres l'ont fait et je
pense qu'il faut se rappeler de la force
de la résilience de nos enseignes en
innu on appelle chip néo chine est aussi
quelqu'un qui est fort qui est capable
d'endurer la douleur la souffrance et
nos ancêtres étaient des gens très très
très courageux braves et qui ont réussi
à nous rendre jusqu'ici la preuve que
c'était des gens braves irrégulière mais
je suis ici aujourd'hui et plus de 100 à
1000 autochtone qui veut au québec c'est
la preuve que nos ancêtres étaient
résilient et ses deux résidences là elle
est à portée il est à une ou deux
générations c'est pas d'histoires
anciennes c'est pas l'histoire du pays
s'annonce et l'histoire du acer est en
terre on à ces jeunes lot de gens très
régulière mais là la colonisation les
pensionnats le le le récit ce système
est bouleversée ça donc il faut
reprendre ses séquelles telle de nos
ancêtres et en faire quelque chose de
fantastique être fiers de célébrer notre
fierté notre culture notre langue une
douche ensemble et notre notice toit ni
comment on fait ça je pense que c'est en
faisant des programmes de promotion de
la vie tu sais dire tu sais pas jusqu'où
pas seulement prévenir la maladie
mentale maladie physique spirituelle et
une approche globale et je pense que les
devoirs des gens sortir de leur de leur
facebook de l'ordinateur et d'aller
commencé à serrer la main de leurs
voisins parce que moi j'avais quand
j'étais jeune il y avait pas de facebook
les genres est rentré la maison on sent
prêt et des lampes raid est importante
aujourd'hui on voit que ce soit dans nos
communautés des gens sont enfermés nahd
dans dollarama leur facebook ils
deviennent solitary s'isole et l'
isolement nous fait du mal
donc il faut apprendre à célébrer notre
communauté puis à célébrer le fait
d'être ensemble mamou ouvrons-nous le
manitou nous sommes aussi très
thématique très importante et mon grand
père m'a toujours dit ma moto et il y en
a nous serons ensemble survivent tas de
bâtir des ponts nano est séparée mourant
très résiliente résiliente savait que
six salles y avait trop de chasseurs
qu'elle survive donc il faut qu'on
concentre mettent ensemble oui et qu'on
brise notre isolation
alors je disais cette émission elle a
été enregistré le 8 février et vous
l'avez entendu dans l'extrait de docteur
volant parle de ceux d'un de ses amis
qui est en crise à ce moment là donc le
8 février et il nous disait bon après
l'émission je vais aller le voir pour
l'aider
évidemment moi je voulais savoir comment
allaient son ami parce qu'on est rendu
maintenant à la fin du mois de juin
comment il se porte et deux acteurs
volant nous a rassuré son ami se porte
bien il a retrouvé lui aussi le goût à
la vie alors c'est tant mieux
également à l'émission nous avions reçu
tatum crunch pas si vous vous rappelez
des lads est originaire de la communauté
des 100 auto c'est acquis reserve en
saskatchewan
mais elle a été sortie de sa famille
très jeune comme beaucoup d'enfants
autochtones elle a été adoptée et elle a
été adoptée par une famille au québec
alors terme crâne en plus de ne pas
porter un nom habituel à une vie tout à
fait inhabituel elle pratique un métier
non conventionnelles un métier que peu
de femmes font en réalité ce que je
devrais dire c'est qu'elle a pratiqué
plusieurs métiers maintenant elle
travaille à la société de transport de
montréal
mais tout au cours de sa vie elle a
pratiqué des métiers non traditionnels
et elle nous en parle est un plus jeune
j'avais pas de facilités au niveau
scolaire donc pour moi j'ai dessiné à ma
mère m'avait demandé de l' l'école puis
bon mais je t'aime passionné de voitures
donc j'ai décidé de commencer en
mécanique automobile pour me rendre
compte assez vite que finalement jamais
pam agresser les mains et puis ya volé
un soudeur puis c'est quelque chose qui
me passionnait donc j'ai transféré de
développer parce que c'était un diplôme
d'études professionnelles
oui donc j'ai fait mon monde et ep en
soudure en soudage-montage puis après je
me spécialiser pour la haute pression et
puis je aller travailler en fait pendant
dix ans pratiquement dix ans comme cela
rassembleur pour
faye grant grosses compagnies donc c'est
ce que j'ai fait c'est quoi ton des
usines qui construisent des autos dans
quoi en fait j'ai travaillé moi je
faisais des systèmes de freinage pour
alstom canada qui était pour les trains
c'est une compagnie sous contractants
qui s'appelait ceinture je travaille et
j'ai fait j'ai fait des traileurs j'ai
fait sur deux projets les gros cheminée
pour les grosses compagnies en fait là
c'est comme une grosse piscine avec une
différence blé puis bon je travaille i
wanna mais ce faire un projet à l'époque
vous étiez dans un métier non
traditionnel n'y avait pas beaucoup de
femmes et en plus vous êtes une femme
autochtone ça fait ça faisait beaucoup
de minorités pour vous là comment vous
avez été reçu par les hommes qui
travaillaient là j'imagine que vous
deviez est une des rares femmes
ouais en fait je vous dirais que le
chemin n'a pas été toujours facile parce
que justement - ce qui est à lui et
c'est que on a tout un test à passer
pour le sceau rouge donc on doit avoir
en fait c'est un test de soudure puis
moi je sortais de l'école donc c'est à
ce moment là c'est avec compagnie qu'on
va savoir si c'est toi qui va faire des
cas qui va avoir des inspections
donc faut pas sûr que ça soit on pense à
toi donc sur les quinze soudards gta
seul qui avait réussi à passer mais je
n'étais la dernière aussi à rentrer fait
que ça n'a pas été facile au sto côté là
puis nous les femmes ont une facilité
une dextérité qui est facile pour le
soudage aux mig oti aussi parce que
c'est très délicat
donc je travaille dans ce métier là je
me suis vraiment spécialisés spécialisés
le dans ce domaine
mais si on les 15 qui était qui est
entré vous étiez la seule femme oui en
fait j'étais la seule femme
donc ça n'a pas été facile sa peau tout
un je te dirai moi j'avais beaucoup de
caractère enfin ed salah est lui
tranquillement je pense qu'on fait
tomber les barrières que vous êtes
passés donc de mécanicien auto way as ou
deux mais ça s'est pas arrêté là
non en fait dans les airs à cassen c'est
hyper intéressant c'est le métier de
soudeur maman née tu avais besoin de
plus toujours derrière un casse et
c'est un travail que oui on parle de
quelque chose
point au jusqu'au point b mais on montre
le projet mais à la toute fin j'avais
besoin de charline jeu puis j'avais un
modèle qui était ma mère que j'avais vu
ma mère poursuivre ses études jusqu'au à
la maîtrise mais je me disais mais
pourquoi que pourquoi moi j'aimerais ça
peut-être je me voyais bien aussi parce
que c'est un métier qui est très
physique donc rentrer chez moi avec les
mains noires puis les brûlures ben c'est
arrivé souvent puis je me voyais pas à
40,50 en face de métier le texte
finalement je décide de retourner à
l'école puis qui était un autre gros
défi parce que bon je pensais que
j'avais que je t'ai pas vraiment bon à
l'école donc je te les faire un dec en
intervention délinquance
puis j'ai poursuivi quelques cours à
l'université puis j'ai travaillé comme
comme agent de programmes pour service
correctionnel canada ou professionnels
au provincial et au fédéral mais c'était
contractuel donc ça a été le monde mon
background club belge tranquillement
j'ai fait des travaux la commission ce
cas là je travaillais pour femmes
autochtones du québec
j'ai fait plusieurs emplois puis moi ce
que je voulais savoir un poste permanent
parce que je voulais fonder ma famille
pour lui c'est important pour moi de
avant une stabilité financière donc et
puis finalement mais y'a quelqu'un qui
m'a dit mais pourquoi tu postules pas
comme comme chauffeur d'autobus pour la
stm le concours est très difficile donc
c'est ce que j'ai fait mais moi ça a été
très rapide vraiment rapide puis au
moment où ce qu'on me dit mais tout est
mannequin vous devez passer de l'examen
de conduite donc je me servirai de bord
je demande aux femmes autochtones du
québec
pouvez vous payer mon cours de conduite
pour véhicules au donc c'est ce que j'ai
fait et puis j'ai commencé à travailler
comme chauffeur d'autobus maintenant
cinq ans que j'ai fait ça pendant 5 1
mais je me suis rendu compte que ça au
sa clientèle c'est pas mon fort
l'expérience donc j'avais besoin de
challenge puis a demandé mais je me suis
dit
j'étais sur le point de quitter il est
temps que quelqu'un me dit applique donc
comme gestionnaire la société de
transport de montréal
je sais ce que j'ai fait sans aucune
pensée sans savoir ce qui s'était coup
elle travaille et puis rendu à deuxième
entrevue
j'ai appelé mon patron pour vour avoir
plus d'informations puis c'est là que je
me rendis compte que en fait la ville de
lorient c'est d'arriver intervenir dans
des situations de crise qui se passe
dans nos autobus les accidents les des
taux les feux oui tout ce qui se passe
quand une personne qui a un malaise
jésus binger doit ses plus beaux
missiles donc j'étais en plus mais à
tous les soirs je rentre chez moi donc
j'ai une qualité de vie et puis ça a été
mon cas ça fait 12 ans que chez thales
et là j'aurais pu vous parler et vous
faire entendre beaucoup de monde mais le
temps passe notre dernier c'est alexis
wawanoloath at alexis c'est le premier
autochtone
élu depuis l'obtention du droit de vote
des premières nations au québec c'était
en 1969
alexis c'est un abénakis mais il est né
à val d'or au québec et avec lui il a
été question de gouvernance parce qu'il
en connaît un chapitre sur la question
dont je lui ai demandé quelle structure
de gouvernance souhaitent les
autochtones comment devenir maître de sa
destinée
ça se fait avec les processus qu'on voit
habituellement des négociations
intervient mais ça serait aussi dans
l'action directe tout qu'est-ce qui
était à domont mardi les résultats de
ces actions directes ou viennent souvent
faire en sorte que la gouvernance va
changer est ce que on a revu la
commission royale sur les peuples
autochtones sa réalité de la crise donc
est ce que on avait eu la commission sur
les femmes autochtones a porté disparu
sa responsabilité dans les dom au world
à la mobilisation
je pense que ça peut être une étable
justement de se réapproprier un cadre
quitte à nous aussi parce que qu'est-ce
qui est
difficile avec une négociation puis avec
l'autonomie gouvernementale comme elles
soient proposées c'est qu'on reste quand
même dans un cadre où on va vous
déléguez vous reconnaître des pouvoirs
et on va vous les délégués c'est tout le
talent à la couronne qui délègue ses
pouvoirs l'on n'est pas dans un partage
la souveraineté comme ça devrait être
parce qu'on n'a jamais vraiment céder
nos territoires au québec à part la baie
james puis qu'est-ce qui traitait par la
convention de la baie james
puis après ça si on se réfère votre été
numérotées ils n'ont pas été faites dans
des mesures où il y avait du
consentement ou il ya main libre
consentement donc à la base mais il faut
falloir voir quelque part la fondation
soit du canada si on veut regarder ça
s'use nautique fédéraliste canadienne ou
d'un éventuellement dans une république
québécoise va falloir en arriver à des
traités conditionnelle ou on se partage
la souveraineté puis où se partage de
souveraineté là ça fait non seulement
sur le territoire aussi sur les
individus mis à penser à toutes les
les autochtones qui vivent en ville oui
exactement parce qu'elle cette réalité
là aussi ce sont des gens son territoire
ils sont ici en vinyle ouais donc d'un
côté il pourra voir ce qu'ils ont compté
on voit que dans notre monde actuel le
libéralisme la propriété individuelle
on est dans la faillite de ce
aujourd'hui on s'en vont vers l'est à
l'instruction on est dans la sixième
extinction l'air anthropocène l'air de
l'humanité et il serait très intéressant
de renverser ou si les perspectives où
on a tout le temps été influencée dans
notre identité qu'on pourrait appeler
constitutionnel par les pouvoirs
coloniaux
il serait intéressant de voir justement
que nos valeurs nos façons de faire
notre philosophie basée non pas basé sur
la propriété individuelle puis sur le
temps linéaire comme on le voit dans la
philosophie libérale qui veut tout
contrôler a beaucoup d'égards de baser
sur le territoire sur le fait que
l'humain est partie du territoire
d'ordonner une nouvelle identité à un
éventuel état qui pourrait se faire avec
les autochtones n'ont pas dominé les
autochtones alors quelle structure ça
pourrait prendre une structure ça
pourrait prendre dans les travaux j'ai
fait dernièrement puis les réflexions
j'ai eu
il faut qu'il ya eu une restitution dans
une certaine mesure il n'y aura pas de
justice on propage suisse par les
structures tout ça faut qu'un une
restitution
puis la gestion doit se faire d'un point
de vue économique de point de vue
culturel
d'un point de vue plus global ou 6 2
parce que la restitution c'est pas juste
le territoire territorialement ça va
très important parce que comme j'ai dit
dans beaucoup dans la majorité des
peuples des premières nations
le territoire est centrale donc la
restitution va falloir qu'elles soient
non seulement territoriales mais
culturel moi par exemple mon arrière
grand mère il ya empêcher de parler là
benaki comment on peut ramener justement
la fin quand on nous a enlevé notre
culture vraiment on peut
ça va être une économie qu on ne s'est
pas invitée à participer à l'économie en
général on nous attend nous vu des yeux
comme des nuisances
on a commencé à naître des réserves
quand on est devenu une nuisance pour
l'exploitation de ce territoire qu'un le
blocus de napoléon l'autre bord pis les
anglais sont venus chercher leurs gros
ici pour faire mal voyants navy on était
plus des partenaires de commerce
immunitaire on était devenu l'ennemi
sens parce qu'on allait chercher la
ressource sur le toit puis avait des
intérêts
donc comment l'on ne fait participer à
cette économie leur pic addax était qu
un ami de l'homme ou si prompts à voir
novara parce que si on prend tout le
temps mal modèle occidental capitaliste
qui détruit on arrive devant vous mêmes
résultats que hong hong et puis
qu'est-ce qu'on y redevient jusqu'à ce
que le people à damas la société
dominante
et oui mais là vous parlez de
restitution les pouvoirs en place tant
fédéral que provincial
ouais c'est ça c'est sa voix tant pis la
participation des attaques tant dans la
sphère aussi dans des institutions qui
devrait être permanente
je les mets en vie par exemple qui ont
une commission parlementaire permanent
pour les affaires ma vie dans le monde
est-ce qu'on pourrait pas avoir un forum
permanent comme c'était inscrit dans la
loi qu'il reconnaissait les peuples
autochtones en 1985 la première loi en
amérique du nord qui reconnaissait les
autochtones avait ça dans son corps qui
devrait y avoir un forum permanent de
consultation
on n'est jamais appliqué ce boulot de la
loire et en quelle année 185 points
c'est pas vieux
c est ce que éventuellement on pourrait
avoir une réforme de nos institutions
représentatives t on parle d'un d'avoir
un portable des fois une deuxième chance
qui serait la chambre des régions avant
leur présentation dégénère en plus de
représentation par la population il
serait intéressant d'avoir une chambre
des régions et des nations où il
pourrait avoir deux représentants des
régions représente un homme et femme de
chaque nation quand même avec calle
questions dont sites éditoriaux aussi
qui touche les premières nations
on a aidé comité spécial puisque c'est
ce côté le souhaitent
initialement consulter oui donc il
existe toutes sortes de modèles dans le
monde
c'est juste une volonté et le politique
pour la tripe ses solutions là ont été
décrites dans des commissions
parlementaires comme la commission
royale sur les peuples autochtones
c'est juste qu'on n'a jamais eu le
courage politique de mettre en action si
profonde rédaction on nous oublie
je vous souhaite un bon été à tous merci
d'avoir été présent tout au long de la
saison des espaces autochtone en direct
et je vous invite cet été à faire le
tour du québec du canada d'aller vous
promener dans les parois ou dans les
festivals autochtone vous allez
découvrir des tas de gens hyper
intéressant et moi je vous donne rendez
vous le 23 août prochain
on était au revoir
[Musique]